what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm
starting a new series on the channel so
as you guys know i have a live show
three days a week and what i do is i
invite people that i you know fought a
little bit with
on the live show onto the channel so
this um series is called conversations
with a feminist
hello hi i'm shimari i am
some pearl some me
so um the reason i invited you was
because you did say that you were a
feminist
and today um something we disagreed on
was
i think what was it on the show it was
like how we
like we started talking about like um
like
systemic issues and then also like the
socioeconomic disposition that people
have yeah and um so i decided to pull up
a clip of ben shapiro's because
he's pretty
controversial and i've actually never
seen this video so i don't know what
it's gonna say but apparently he's
debunking systemic racism which i
believe in yeah so
let's let's start the video then you
ready
okay
okay so there's a video that is going
around on facebook smash your past ben
shapiro
pass
okay just wait what are you doing
so
uh
no i'm he's not really my type
i got a very specific type
i do i do love him though i really do i
love ben shapiro but no pass
book and on youtube it's from act tv
called systemic racism explain make some
interesting arguments and i thought it's
worthwhile going through them a little
bit so we're going to play the video
we'll stop it we'll discuss this video
is sponsored by the benham brothers
brand new course expert ownership you
can learn to own a business without it
owning you stick around to the end of
the video to find out more details this
is jamal jamal is a boy who lives in a
poor neighborhood he has a friend named
kevin who lives in a wealthy
neighborhood all of jamal's neighbors
are african-american and all of kevin's
neighbors are white because jamal's
school district is mostly funded by
property taxes his school is not very
well funded his classrooms are
overcrowded his teachers are underpaid
and he doesn't have access to high
quality tutors or extracurricular
activities kevin's school district is
also funded by property taxes so his
school is very well funded his
classrooms are never crowded his
teachers are very well paid and he has
access to high quality tutors and lots
of extracurricular activities so let's
talk for a second about school policy
what do you think of that
i believe everything that they just said
okay this is what i was saying on the
show yeah this is what so my
opinion is i actually do think if
there's one piece of systemic racism
today it's schools
okay i do agree
but i don't necessarily think it's about
race
because it's based on where you live
but my opinion is that the left actually
is horrible
for
um education because they don't believe
in charter schools
and i think charter do you know what a
charter school is
not necessarily because it's like
um
it's like private school kind of but
it's public school that's all i know
okay so i'll just i'll just tell you
like so i'm from chicago right so in
chicago the state in the the chicago
public schools the state gives you
thirteen thousand dollars per kid
so each school when they get a kid they
get thirteen thousand dollars
and it's my opinion that um
you shouldn't be forced like i was from
a wealthy family they could pay for me
to go to private school but i don't
think it's fair that if you're born into
a poor family like you should be forced
to go to a shitty school yeah definitely
and the the way you can get around that
is charter schools because a charter
school you can um
basically
like it would give the parents the right
to say hey i don't want my kid in that
school let's put him in that school and
give that's like a different school the
thirteen thousand dollars per kid
but the left is like adamantly against
this
which i think is crazy because they'll
fight for education but like they won't
pass the policies that would help people
that are the most impoverished does that
make sense
so i actually agree if there's any form
of systemic racism it would be schools
okay what do you what do you think no i
100 agree okay
would you so would you support the
charter schools
like where the the parent so if you had
a kid you would say hey you get 13 000
to give a school yeah versus going like
going off like because that would be
equally dividing the money versus where
the money from a certain neighborhood is
going into that neighborhood school yeah
when the public school is meant to be
for everyone yes but it's not benefiting
everyone yeah yeah that sounds good okay
we'll see the reality is that if you
wanted jamal to be able to go to kevin's
school what you'd want is something
called school vouchers you want people
to be able to this is the same thing i'm
talking about he's calling it school
vouchers but it's like the same thing i
think it's a bit different though
because um where i'm from we have magnet
schools which is still like regular
public schools we do have charter
schools but so um like there's public
charter and
did i say public already so private
private public charter and yeah
magnum is it called no
magnet but magnet
magnet is in a
public schools so basically
there are home they're called
neighborhood schools so it would be for
your neighborhood and then the magnet
schools are schools that are
specialized in different things so
they're like uh there's an art magnet
school there's like science college prep
like there are so many different kinds
of
magnet schools but they are
funded the same way that a neighborhood
school would be they're actually funded
like by whatever neighborhood they're in
kind of um and then
you can apply to go there and then they
accept you are not to go there so is it
like you have to be of a certain
academic requirement or something
or is it by lottery do you know it's
lottery okay because charter is by
lottery too is it
okay i don't i don't know the difference
like between the like i i've never heard
of the schools you're talking about is
it because they're more specific to be
like an art school or something or music
yeah like the they're different
categories so like for middle school i
went to a medical magnet
okay um then high school i just went to
like another magnet school but
that's interesting i've never heard of
the magnet but i just know charter it's
i know it's by lottery but i know that
you would get the money that the state
would normally give to the school in
your district would go to the charter
school that's that's what i understand
but maybe he'll maybe ben will let us
know
move away from their school districts
one of the chief reasons that jamal is
confined to his local public school is
because of democratic policy that has
decided that you must go to school in
the district where you live and this is
also why a lot of people have left lower
income areas and moved out to higher
income areas specifically for better
public schools so if you want jamal to
have the same educational opportunities
as kevin perhaps you should have school
vouchers for private schools or perhaps
you should have charter schools which is
what mayor bill de blasio new york is
fighting against or perhaps you should
break the teachers unions which are
costing a fortune particularly on a
disproportionate level in areas where
they're not spending enough taxpayer
dollars so i'm all for improving jamal
schools i'm also offered jamal having
all the same educational opportunities
as kevin the problem is most democrats
are not kevin and jamal live only a few
streets away from each other so how come
they're growing up in such different
worlds with such different opportunities
for success the answer has to do with
america's history of systemic racism to
understand it better let's look at what
life was like for kevin and jamal's
grandparents in order to understand
what's going to happen in this video you
have to understand how systemic racism
is being defined systemic racism is
really amorphous term it could mean many
things it could mean that the
institutions of today are racist in
which case everyone would oppose them or
it could mean that all inequality is
explainable by racism which of course is
not sustainable it's not a good argument
the argument that this video is going to
try to make is that all of history has
meaning and that is true history does
have consequences for today the problem
is as we'll see the video tries to
explain all inequality with reliance on
history and no inequality with response
to
exacerbating levels of income inequality
exacerbating levels of single motherhood
personal decision making or any of the
other variables that could come into
creating the gaps we see today decades
after the civil war many government
agencies started to draw maps dividing
cities into sections that were either
desirable or undesirable for investment
this practice was called redlining and
it usually blocked off entire black
neighborhoods from access to private and
public investment banks and insurance
companies used these maps for decades to
deny black people loans and other
services based purely on race
historically speaking owning a home and
getting a college education is the
easiest way for an american family to
build wealth but when jamal's
grandparents wanted to buy a house the
banks refused because they lived in a
neighborhood that was redlined so
jamal's grandparents were not able to
buy a home and because colleges could
prevent them from attending through
legal segregation their options for
higher education were really scarce so
let's talk about redlining redlining
became illegal in the united states as
early as 1968 the equal credit
opportunity act was followed by the home
mortgage disclosure act of 1975 which
was a predecessor to the community
reinvestment act both of which were an
attempt to ensure that people who are
living in low-income minority
neighborhoods could actually get loans
and these things were very effective in
1992 researchers at the federal reserve
bank of boston tried to look at the data
they collected information on some 30
variables related to lending decisions
they found that virtually all of the
difference between minority and
non-minority denial rates was explained
by those variables a re-analysis of that
information found that black-owned banks
were actually lending to white-owned
businesses at higher rates than they
were lending to black-owned businesses
furthermore if it seemed that banks were
discriminating against black borrowers
on the basis of they needed to have
higher credit qualifications what you
would see is lower default rates from
black clients of banks from people who
are borrowing money from banks in the
black community there are zero studies
that show any of this so the bottom line
is this redlining was an evil and awful
policy it was made illegal in the 1960s
by the 1980s the banks were not lending
at disproportionate rates in fact if you
look among different communities as tom
assol has pointed out asian americans
get loans more easily than white
americans that does not mean the banks
are being racist toward white americans
on behalf of asian americans when it
comes to college education it is also
worth noting that yes there are many
universities that were segregated there
were many universities that did not
allow black people to attend since the
1970s the most prominent measure that
has been used in order to admit black
students to major universities across
the country has been affirmative action
which actively discriminates against
people who are not black in favor of
black applicants specifically by
ensuring that black applicants don't
have to have the same test scores or
gpas in order to get into those same
schools so not only has policy been
corrected it's been over-corrected in
these areas
okay what do you think
i'm hearing what he's saying i'm just
on the other side of like knowing the
reality that like not necessarily the
reality for myself but the reality like
of people before me or other people
because i am i am a privileged person
and i can acknowledge that but like for
other people
um that look like me
do you so like what did you think he was
wrong about like which part
saying that um like even the last thing
he said like okay like redlining ended
at this time so like at this point
everyone has like fair game but it's not
a fair game if you are winning all the
games before
and now you get to let me play equally
like say you know like how people like
take their like little sibling and say
you have like three older siblings and
it's like oh yeah i'll let them play but
then they're not letting them play and
then like eventually the mom is like let
them play so then they're playing but
they weren't playing the whole time they
could only play after
like however long that they were playing
so it's not an equal advantage
especially if you are already having a
house or whatever
so question do you think that if you
were born after the 70s like and in that
case like it doesn't you can't really
blame it on a law that was passed in the
70s like like for example um a lot of
people talk about the differences
between men and women um
like the income differences between men
and women they'll say like i've had
girls on my show say it was because we
couldn't vote and because we didn't have
access to any of those things but to me
i'm like well that doesn't affect me i
was born in
20 20 21 like what does that have to do
with me wait i'm sorry you're saying
that they said that what has no effect
so so what i'm saying is do you think if
they were born after like if they were
born in 2000 someone's 22
like like you can't really blame a law
from the 70s on how your life turned out
in 2022 it has an effect okay so your
view is that like you feel like it's a
trickle effect a triple effect trickle
oh a trickle yeah like
like a domino effect
a domino but like it just doesn't make
sense to me because it's like like my
dad was broke and he
like and he he he lived on the south
side of chicago yeah but if the bank is
giving him like the bank is um more
likely to give him
um money or like different things like
that
er
is going to be on his benefit so he's
able to be on the upper hand so even if
he didn't start out like rich and
obviously like a lot of people are broke
yeah and that's reality yeah but even
even if you're
you're white or whatever
like you're gonna have a better chance
of
making money rather than
a black person so just do you think that
if um
the reason that they were denied is for
their credit scores because that's what
he was saying he's saying there was a
study that said it wasn't anything to do
with race it was about their credit
score like they had lower credit do you
think that's systemically racist
no i don't i don't think it's based off
of the credit like obviously that has a
factor but they're they're like it's
it's much deeper than just saying like
um like
yeah this is like so we made this role
and after this role everything is
perfect no everything's not going to be
perfect after after these things like
well i agree i think generational wealth
is a thing yeah but so it ties into that
like well i i just think like it's it's
for me it's about like the world view
like every time there's there's always
going to be inequality between groups
like you know the highest um
earning
income like the highest paid group in
the us is indian americans
so like they have they have like they're
very dark right
and they they outpace whites
and so it's like you can't like i feel
like a lot of times the left like the
first
reaction is that it's either about like
race or gender or something when they
see an inequality but if you have two
groups like the odds are they're not
gonna be exactly the same
yeah but i i don't believe in like the
whole like uh like people of color and
black people because
like obviously there are
uh
a lot of minorities in america but i
don't think that all minorities have the
same experience and i think yeah i think
the electrical cannot be
put in like people of color is like a
nice thing to try and make all of all
the people that are not white to be
together but it's like that's not the
reality like you don't have the same
disposition or experience to say like
you just have the same
hue like you have uh closer hues
but that doesn't change anything to me
do you so this is i think i might have
asked you on the show but sometimes i
think it's like
like racist uh to just assume everyone
has the same experience because of their
skin color that's not racist
well because like it's making an
assumption about someone based on the
color of their skin that's not what
racism is
um
okay so where where do you feel like i'm
wrong
like
i i get what you're saying but that that
would be something different like you're
just you're just saying that it's wrong
to assume but no one's saying that
you're you have to have a great life
because you're white or that because
you're black you're automatically going
to have a terrible life
it's just
a
a fact and
i would say this based on experience
like like
i'll have to say it's a fact based on
experience um
but
um it doesn't mean that you're
automatically going to have the worst
life or the best life okay it just means
that it's more likely
that's to sit and if if more people
are experiencing these things
and
yeah like it's just
more likely it doesn't it's not 100 so
that would be the exception
so
um
if there were if there were like
subgroups of like
that of um
like for example i i want to say
americans are very close economically to
whites but that's like a subgroup of
people that are black
do you say do you so do you think that's
different if like a subgroup is very
similar to in terms of like economically
outpacing whites i think they're that's
a bit different because they're
they're immigrants mm-hmm so like
it's a different like
it's it's weird explaining because that
then goes to like another like it's
connected but it's a subcategory of like
the original thing
so
well i'm just i'm just curious if it's
different if like if if a subgroup is
similar like do you feel like when
you're talking about like the black
experience that just
is that everybody under the same
like everybody that's black yeah i would
say that everyone that's black and like
obviously even they're gonna be i'm
sorry like say like the exception so
there's always gonna be the exception
right so it's it's never saying that a
hundred percent of people have this
experience is the fact that
most of the people have this experience
okay
okay i'll keep going kevin's
grandparents on the other hand got a low
interest loan to buy their first house
and get accepted into a handful of top
universities which traditionally only
accepted white students this opened up a
wealth of opportunities that they were
able to pass on to their kids and
grandkids the basic assumption of this
video is that if your grandparents are
rich in the united states this means
that you are rich in the united states
and if your grandparents are poor in the
united states that means that you are
poor in the united states this is
factually untrue the reality is that
income changes over time that there are
an enormous number of people in the
united states by percentage who are able
to rise from poor to middle class and
their children from middle class to
wealthy the biggest problem that we have
in the united states right now is not a
historic wealth gap the biggest problem
we have is an income gap in the united
states and there's some fascinating
statistics surrounding this there's a
harvard study recently that showed that
black males were growing up in the same
household incomes as white males were
actually underperforming their white
male counterparts even in high income
neighborhoods you would think that all
of this might imply racism except for
one inconvenient fact in the study black
women who are growing up in the same
high-income neighborhoods as white women
growing up in the same high-income
neighborhoods black women were
performing at exactly the same or higher
rates than white women in those
neighborhoods which would suggest that
there are other factors at play other
than simple racism furthermore the basic
idea that most wealth in the united
states is inherited and the millionaires
are really only millionaires because
their parents were millionaires that
really isn't true either the vast
majority of millionaires and
billionaires are people whose parents
were not millionaires and billionaires
chris hogan who's a black friend
all right i just i'm disagreeing because
it's like no no one's saying that
every rich person is going to be rich
and like obviously like say if i have
money i could lose all of my money today
and then so my hypothetical kids they
they won't have they won't be rich or
they won't have wealth in that sense
because i've just lost all of all of my
money but
it's saying that you have the upper hand
like
you you will have if you have something
like if you start with something and you
gradually add more
you will always like be able to add more
but say if you have nothing and then
you can't like necessarily like add in
the same sense so if that's true why
aren't the majority of millionaires why
weren't their parents millionaires
no that's what i'm saying i'm not saying
it doesn't matter
that like obviously you can earn money
without being rich like you just have to
be able to be able to like save
something and then be able to flip it
however you do it you just have to you
have to like if you're starting with
nothing you have to come up with
something and then once you come up with
something then you have to be able to
like save it and then flip it some way
or another but the thing is like most
people don't have the opportunity to
even like start saving
right but what i'm asking is for like
like if you if there's any evidence that
you know of to support this because if
what you're saying is true i would think
that the majority of millionaires and
billionaires in this country would have
come from millionaires and billionaires
i wouldn't think so
well and i'm saying this from experience
right so then wouldn't that indicate the
opposite that it's not really so much
about
where you come from it's rather your
decisions
they both play a factor
um yeah i'm not saying it doesn't play
any factor but wouldn't you say like in
that case then it's more based on your
decisions no i think it's like
equal like legally aligning okay like
they both play a factor you can't take
one without the other okay in my book is
there if you ever saw evidence that like
would you ever change your opinion on
this if you saw the right evidence
um i would be willing to look at the
evidence but like i'm saying from
things that i've seen and so many people
like it's not just like i'm like blindly
saying like oh like yeah i'm like no
like this is the reality for so many
people um
this is reality for so many people
well cause it's just in my experience
like i come from a wealthy family right
but there's there's
there's people in my family that will be
broke forever yeah that like like i have
um
i'm not gonna put who it is on blast but
there's someone in my family that spends
money like like it's water like he will
it does not matter he could he he comes
from a family that gives him everything
but because of his decisions
he he will literally like do nothing and
i came from a family where my dad worked
80 hours a week my whole life and i just
don't think most people want to do that
like and if i had to say
like i i don't think it would have
mattered where my dad started
like he started broke he was going to be
rich regardless because you you put in
80 hours a week for 30 years you're
going to be ahead of 90 people
like who because who does that
like i don't i don't know anyone that
works that much do you
my grandma does yeah okay because she's
not even like like she she's like
working to survive
it's not even to where like she's
working working and it's like she's like
she's she has to work
what does your grandma do
um
she i'm not gonna say i cannot say okay
you can't but she works yeah yeah i was
just wondering because i do think it's
like partially like
like there's more than one factor but in
my eyes it's more like personal like
choices rather than your environment
because i've just seen i've just seen
too many successful people where i'm
from that came from nothing
i'm not saying that there can't be
successful people like even one of my
cousins yeah he's a self-made
millionaire like multi-millionaire um
and
he has the same like
he has the same like
disposition that i'm saying that most
people have
but he was able to
come out of that so i'm not saying that
it's not possible i'm just saying it's
very hard to okay
okay let's let's keep going
financial expert he did a survey of ten
thousand people and what he found was
that of those 10 000 people 74 percent
of millennials believed millionaires
inherited their money 52 of baby boomers
did but only 21 percent of millionaires
received any inheritance at all just 16
inherited more than a hundred thousand
dollars only three percent receives an
inheritance at or above one million
dollars in reality the best path toward
wealth in this country is income
mobility not inherited wealth this
opened up a wealth of opportunities that
they were able to pass on to their kids
and grandkids even as late as the 1980s
an investigation into the atlanta real
estate market showed that one quick
question did that study make you think
differently or would you feel like it's
the same
what the one the one
yeah no i don't think that every every
person that has wealth came from wealth
okay i do think that you can earn your
wealth okay i just the point is that
it's hard and that there are a lot of
things in place to
stop you or like yeah just stop you
along the way okay
banks were more willing to lend to
low-income white families than to middle
or upper-income african-american
families as a result today for every
hundred dollars of wealth held by a
white family black families have five
dollars and four cents a 2017 study
confirms that redlining is still
affecting home values in major cities
like chicago today this explains how
kevin and jamal inherited vastly
different circumstances as it turns out
there are some complicating factors that
don't get cited in this video with
regard to this data the federal reserve
board economists tried to explain that
this data did not take account of
differences that were not income based
things like liabilities employment
history credit record and other relevant
variables that should have been
considered it should not be particularly
surprising that discrimination in the
past has impact on the actual income of
people who are living in the areas that
were denied loans that shouldn't be a
major surprise but that is not the only
disparity obviously that new york times
piece they are citing says quote they
estimate the maps account for 15 to 30
of the overall gaps in segregation and
home ownership that they find between
the highest risk area and the second
highest risk areas those were the ones
that were being classified the truth is
that when it comes to redlining you have
to look at the gradations as well
there's always going to be a difference
in the availability of loans to people
who are living in the highest risk areas
as opposed to the people who are in the
very lowest risk areas another factor is
that if history does make a difference
than if you are denied loans in a
particular area and if there's less
money in those areas and as crime goes
up and as property taxes kick in there's
not enough money to take and as schools
get worse obviously that's going to
continue to have effect in that
particular area that doesn't mean the
same people are living in that area who
always lived in that area or the people
who grew up in that area in 1960
necessarily have to live in that area or
that their grandkids have to live in
that area in 2020. unfortunately the
story doesn't end there a big part of
systemic racism is implicit bias these
are prejudices in society that people
are not aware that they have one of the
big problems with implicit bias it is
very very difficult to quantify identify
and studies that supposedly determine
that your implicit bias results in real
world action are deeply flawed implicit
bias assessment tests for example are so
significantly flawed they're virtually
unusable let's go back to kevin and
jamal against all odds jamal manages to
be the only student from his high school
to get accepted into a great university
the same one that kevin and his high
school first quick question do you think
quotas are okay
you're getting good so um a quota is
basically like when um colleges
say because of like oh oh
about um
what is it uh when it's like oh you're
led in because of your race
no it's it's when colleges have like
are told to let in a certain amount of
people because of their race what is
that called though um
there's
like say you could say to me they let
you in because you're black
because they have to like fill that
quota but what is that called
where they have to let you in because of
a quota
so it's um
there's another word i can't think of it
um okay but so do you think it's okay
for companies and and schools to say
we need to have this many black people
here
i think it is to where
you should allow these people into your
spaces will like not allow interior
spaces where like um
where everyone has an opportunity to
come in um
because a lot of times it's just like
say say you have a company
and it's like i'm only gonna let like
the white people i know and i'm not
gonna like allow but maybe i'll let like
one one like
other race end so it's like i'm not
racist but
no no i'm not talking about that so i'm
talking about so let's let's take
harvard okay yeah their average act
score is 34.
or like let's let's say do you do you
guys have a cts
yeah okay i forget everyone has well
there's some states just do sats that
was why oh
we'd do both okay okay so let's say it's
like 34. and basically if
maybe 80 of the people coming are either
white asian whatever and there's a lower
percentage like let's say they only get
two percent black people that like want
to come
do you think they should lower the
standards to let black people end so
then say okay we need more black people
to come in so let's let the people in
with like a 30. i don't i don't think
necessarily that i think the issue is is
say if we're ever if everyone is
applying um as an unmarked person so
you're just going based off of their
stats so you can see
my gpa
my like how i'm testing on a on a
national level and
like say like volunteer hours because we
do have to have that
so say you're looking at those things
and you're gonna call each person like
zero one
zero two and so forth there's no name
involved there's no race there's no sex
like just go in like based off of solely
their merit rather than yeah okay i
agree just that so um
would you be okay
if let's say harvard does that and it's
like 90 asian people
i wouldn't care because that means that
they were all given the equal
opportunity to get in there and it had
nothing to do
aside from their merit okay because we
agree then so you would be okay with
them getting rid of like quotas
yeah yeah because it actually it hurts
like um it's it's sad because a lot of
the people that say they're like helping
black people by letting them in it makes
them feel dumb if you lower the
standards so if you let in someone
like there was a study done and they
look at the schools that use quotas and
black kids were flunking out faster
because they felt dumb because they
weren't qualified to go to the school
even if they're smarter than like 80
percent ninety percent of the population
does that make sense because they're
lowering the standards to let them end
where's the study and um it's in thomas
sowell
thomas has a book called the decline in
dogma of american education
and so he like he breaks it down by like
by because these are the schools that
admittedly use quotas it's not like it
was a secret
does that make sense yeah no you're
saying so but i'm saying like it hurt
people because me like if they let me
into harvard because they needed a
ginger like i would feel stupid even
though i'm smarter than most people
statistically but i would i would feel
dumb
yeah yeah but like i think we agree
right like that's messed up yeah you
just let people go off their merit not
yeah anything to do with them sorry we
agree yeah yeah yeah
friends are attending but after kevin
and jamal both graduate jamal notices
that his resume isn't drawn as much
interest as kevin's even though they
graduated from the same program with the
exact same gpa unfortunately for jamal
studies show that resumes with white
sounding names get twice as many
callbacks as identical resumes with
black sounding names the research is
actually a lot more interesting than
what is being portrayed in this video
there are several studies here there is
one famous study that was done that
suggested that first name
differentiation was indeed being used by
employers so if your name was lakisha
for example this is the name that is
actually used in the study lakisha
versus greg that you are less likely to
get a callback there's another study
that showed a historically black last
name like washington or jefferson
provided no actual differentiation from
historically white names a greenberg for
example so if your name was steve
greenberg versus steve jefferson you're
just as likely to get a call back as
steve jefferson what that suggests and
this was confirmed by subsequent studies
is that the actual issue here is a
question of class discrimination not an
issue of race discrimination in other
words the reason that people are
discriminating against lakisha as
opposed to against steve johnson or
steve washington is because people are
actually using the first name as a
stand-in for social class they are
figuring that if you were named lakisha
it's because you probably came from a
more impoverished background now this is
not restricted to the black community
this happens in the jewish community as
well if you get an applicant and the
applicant's name is ben you might treat
that applicant different than if that
person's name is benjamin you might
treat a menachem different than you
treat a mic and that is because you are
trying to read into the person your
perceptions of culture or perceptions of
class not really perceptions of race
that's really really important when you
look at these particular studies and
suggest that racial discrimination i
think class discrimination is a thing i
actually agree yeah
like i
i think
like yeah i think like lower um
yeah i could see that
i can see what he's saying but i think
i think
i think i will have to say like the the
how he's saying like their background
that they're like i think it goes back
to the disposition of like where they
would have to be at so even if someone
didn't want to be who wants to be poor
let's start there but even if someone
didn't like necessarily like if they
were actually like working to not be
saved like say if a black person on your
dad's side like say how your dad is like
working how you're saying he's working
as much as he's working um
if he was a black person and maybe like
there are like different factors in that
keep him to be poor
um
i think that could play a factor in
their and their
where their environment of what he's
saying of how they're going off of name
like base of their class not their race
but i think it can go hand in hand but
that is interesting to see and i know
that that is like true because um
even like within the past month i was
applying for like different jobs and
stuff and i i did apply twice i had
everything the same everything the same
i changed my name
and you got a call back
yeah oh wow that's crazy i changed my
name in the email because obviously like
well my email has like part of my first
name but if i change the name like i use
the same surname and everything but um
all the information was identical
another friend of mine uh blackmail
he was applying for this job and the
only thing that you had to do was like
um
fill out this test
uh
and so he took the test he got 100 on
the test like he got every answer
correct and they are like uh
unfortunately you don't meet the
requirements he had um a friend of his
do it for him a girl i don't know what
her race is um
but he told her to put like
say a white name
um and she put it down she got some of
the answers wrong like purposely
and
they're like oh thank you like you meet
everything that we need
whereas he
was it this it was the same resume too
yeah wow that's crazy yeah that's nuts
i mean i could you know what's
interesting people always think i'm
black before i get there no no i swear
to god i've had this happen so many
times because my last name's davis so
it's like pearl davis
i don't know
i don't know why but i've had like at
least four times in my life people say
this to me but when i come in for like
an interview or i used to work in sales
or i had like a roommate once that also
i don't know
i wouldn't i wouldn't i personally
wouldn't think that you were black just
based off of your name like
i don't know why i i'm telling you it's
happened to me more like
it's happened to my brother too his
name's austin i think davis is more of a
black last name yeah
i'm thinking about that the only people
i know that are davis they are black but
i wouldn't think that
that surname makes you inherently a
certain race
yeah i don't know i'm just telling you
my experience with it
rather than class distinctions are at
the basis of whatever hiring
discrimination is happening here
implicit bias is one of the reasons why
the black unemployment rate is twice the
rate of white unemployment well this
tends to neglect one key factor what did
you major in wait do you know what's
interesting blacks were economically
outpacing whites before the 1960s
wait repeat that blacks were
economically outpacing like they're
outpacing whites until the 1960s like
they were
moving up at a faster rate
did you know that until they implemented
the welfare state
what is the will first date they paid
people to like get the dad out of the
home so like women weren't supposed to
oh yeah yeah they were like incentivized
to give to they're given money basically
if the dad like was out of the house
yeah
like that is that messed up
yeah but it's a reality yeah
okay we agree that's master i'm just i'm
trying not
okay
you study it turns out that people who
major in education aren't going to do as
well as people who major in engineering
according to research from the center on
education in the workforce at georgetown
university there's a quote from pbs
african american college students are
more likely to pursue majors that lead
to low-paying jobs setting up many for
future debt and underemployment over
time these occupational choices
contribute to the wealth and opportunity
gap between whites and blacks that spans
generations anthony carnival who's the
director of the program he says
basically african-americans have been
going to the right church but sitting in
the wrong pew in a way they are using
education to climb the social and
economic ladder but they're being
steered toward majors that will make
them low earners so in other words there
are several confounding factors that are
not being taken into account in this
video one what college did you go to two
what did you major in and three what
kind of job did you get afterward you
can see evidence of systemic racism in
every area of life the disparities in
family wealth incarceration rates
political representation and education
are all examples of systemic racism now
we reach the crux of the matter the
basic idea here is that any inequality
can be chalked up to systemic racism we
are now ghost hunting notice they've
said nothing in this video about
incarceration nothing and this is okay
so
a lot of times like people think i don't
think there's any like racism or
systemic issues in society that's not
what i think what i don't like is that
people always assume if there's a
disparity between two groups that it's
because of race
and they don't take it other factors
into account so if i if you see a
disparity between any or gender right so
if you see a disparity between two
groups like like i'll take the gender
gap like one of the reasons there's a
disparity is interests right personality
differences and like there's a million
factors that go into it
and um
i don't know that's that's what i think
of like when i watch this stuff it's
more like
like why is there a gap and why do we
always just assume it's like gender and
race
yeah i can get that
yeah do you disagree yeah because it's
like
it doesn't matter like say like we're
both doing the same job
no matter if i'm a a woman or a male
like we should both be paid the same
like you just i think it's just
everything should be based off merit i
know i agree but sometimes when you let
people choose what they want to choose
like choose when they want to choose so
so for example one of the reasons women
make less than men is because they pick
industries that make less money
so if you look at countries that have
more choice for women the pay graph
increases it doesn't decrease but when
you
take take the different like jobs aside
if you look in like say we're both
working
this we work out the same job doing the
same title
we should be paid the same and
the only difference of like our pay
should come into like the
what should change our pay is um
how long that we've been working there
so like say experience um
not because you're a male and i'm a
female like that should be the only
difference so don't like i i think it's
um unfair to compare like a teacher to
[Music]
a engineer or something because they're
obviously going to have different like
they're going to have a pay gap but you
should compare a teacher and a teacher
and
an engineer and an engineer right but so
then another another thing they don't
take into account is personality
differences like 60 of women have never
asked for a raise so if me and you are
in the same job and let's say i'm the
dude and i ask for a raise three times
and you choose not to
like don't you think then i should get
be paid more because i chose to ask
a lot of i i don't think a lot of guys
ask for a raises and then also no they
do like statistics like they survey
people
and
when i and i get that women do ask for
um
for raises but
uh
what
a lot of people have come out and said
like
whenever they do they're they're
punished in the end for like women
they're punished in the end for asking
for the raise well it's not it's not
necessarily that i mean a lot of times
bosses don't want to pay you more that's
like 100 true but the guy
will not put up with it and he'll leave
so he'll say f this i'm not going to
work for you i'll go find a new job
where the girl will say oh it's fine and
keep working there like it's called the
trait agreeableness to disagreeableness
so like that's that's just one factor
that goes into like why there's a pay
gap and so a lot of times people will
say oh men and women in the same job
they're paid differently but they don't
talk about what the personality
difference is how many times have they
asked for a raise who works puts in more
hours
like men tend to work longer hours
and so it's like
like how can you fault them for paying
them different i don't think men tend to
work longer hours no they do they survey
men and women and they say how many
hours do you work and you put it in
so do you like do you not believe when
it's like people are reporting how many
hours they work but at that point
shouldn't you be paying like comparing
say divide the wage over like hours
worked
not
um comparing someone that works x amount
of time in it like if they're working
different times obviously one person
will will make more so that's not like a
fair comparison well no because we're
most jobs are salary based so it's like
let's say let's say me and you right if
you i work 10 hours a day we have the
same salary starting off and i work 10
hours a day and you work eight
um so then that's an extra oh my god i
can't do math that's an extra 10 hours a
week that's an extra 40 hours a month
but like you add to keep adding that up
in two years i'll be so far ahead of you
you'll never be able to catch up and so
of course i'm gonna get the raise
because i've put in an extra two hours a
day
for however many years
and so i'm gonna be better at my job but
it's like the the mindset is if there's
a disparity it's always discrimination
instead of like sometimes that's just
how the chips fall
does that make sense
yeah you disagree you could you could
say it i mean like
i i would i would that would be
something like i can like look more into
like i'm open to the idea but i do think
like
like basically my my thing is and a lot
in life is like if if uh people if not
just one person but a lot of people are
experiencing something and they're
saying like this is my experience you
can't say oh no this didn't happen like
it's it happened
so you have to acknowledge like that as
something that happened well i'm i'm not
but i think you have to have evidence
that it happened i can't just take
people's word for it
and so like a lot of
like a lot of people i know personally
that are women that like complain about
this type of stuff i know them
personally and i'm like no you're just
lazy like and i'm not trying to be mean
but i see how they act in their other
areas of their life and i'm like
well you don't show up to practice on
time or anything on time so i doubt you
show up to your job on time
and so you're you're crying that like
the guy makes more than you
but i see the decisions you make
and so i can't just take people that i
don't know his words blindly i have to
see some evidence that it's happening
but what if you were to see that
evidence like like
every every person because obviously
like
you can use stats but i don't think
stats are always going to be
like 100 because not every it's not
going to have everyone's opinion in
there
well i don't think everyone like i don't
care about people's opinions i think
well no our experience like like the
reality of things that happen so
like in factual based realities um it's
not going to have that in there like not
for
everyone it will have like some people
so
no i mean i i used to think like that to
be honest a couple years ago
but i don't know i just the more i
learned the more i realized there's like
a lot more that goes into it
but i see like i see where you're coming
from i understand what you're saying i
think you're saying
you want
like you you feel like sometimes the
stats don't
talk about like there's things that
doesn't represent everything like
they're like it will leave some people
out yeah
yeah no i understand that i don't agree
but
um
i don't know i didn't really expect to
yeah what did you was there anything in
this video that surprised you like
what'd you think of the video overall i
think
i think that not necessarily surprised
me but just saying that it could be a
class issue
like um
say not a racial issue but a class issue
but i think
class does go like i i believe in
systemic racism and like i don't think
that will ever change like
i just don't think so just because like
my experience other people's experience
and
i'm just curious if you met people that
were black and had different experiences
would you like would that change your
mind at all i have met people with
different experiences and
like
different walks of life like
different walks of life different
upbringings different
all these different factors but
people can have a lot of things in
common whilst having totally different
realities
and it's like if it's showing up in all
these different ways
yeah
and i don't i don't necessarily think
like it doesn't exist i just it's more
to me it's about
we can't just assume if there's a
disparity it's like based on
discrimination i think there needs to be
more like people need to look into it
more before me yeah i i do think so but
i don't i i don't think anyone's saying
that it is the end-all be-all like
meaning that is 100 all the time
i think
like i was saying it's a it happens most
of the time or to a majority of people
to be able to say xyz not just oh yeah
like
oh pearl's being mean to me and then
say everyone else is being nice but it's
like oh yeah they're all being mean to
me
like
if most people have this reality then
okay well do you have any final thoughts
for the channel um tell them where they
can find you
um would you come back
yeah i'll come back you'll come back
yeah i'll come back you can show me
something you can show me a piece of
content next time that you think i
should see
um
show me something from the left
i'm not i'm really not like either side
i'm just like
i i am i do like to go with more of like
the facts
like but
i think just like being open-minded or
just like willing to hear and like
actually see where people are coming
from is the big thing no that's why
that's why i invited you i felt like we
could have a conversation and not hate
each other right yeah yeah cool
so tell them where they can find you um
you can find me on the pearly the pearl
show um the pre-game yeah pregame show
with just pearly things um but other
than that
i don't exist
unless you want to hire me
i don't exist okay
um okay guys well thank you so much for
coming on i really appreciate it i think
these conversations are important that
we talk to people that disagree with us
um because it's it's not fun for just
only talking to people that agree so
guys you already know the deal if you've
watched two or more of my videos and you
don't subscribe we have beef so
subscribe like the video on your way out
and i will talk to you guys next time